[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le 7-8 l'hebdo
ravi de vous retrouver pour ce dernier
numéro de la saison au sommaire ce
vendredi 17 juillet ce week-end les
départs en vacances sur les routes sont
prévues nombreux bison futé voit rouge
le ministre des transports jean baptiste
g paris s'est rendu sur le péage de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines pour faire le
point pour vos vacances dans les
yvelines vous avez sûrement envie de
grand air pour vous éclairer sur les
activités possibles nous aurons avec
nous les responsables de la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet et l'île des
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
les élus communautaires installés à
saint quentin en yvelines philippe
benassaya choisi pour représenter la
droite aux législatives partielles de la
11e circonscription et valérie pécresse
en visite à l'usiné renault de flins
nous reviendront sur les moments forts
de l'actualité de la semaine dans votre
département
c'est le début du troisième week-end des
vacances d'été à la veille des grands
départs le ministre délégué en charge
des transports jean baptiste gpar il
s'est rendu dans plusieurs sites de
l'autoroute a10 et notamment à la barre
de péage de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
très fréquentée malgré la crise
sanitaire
l'occasion de rappeler quelques messages
de prévention grégory canal et ce
vendredi matin sur l'autoroute a10 les
automobilistes étaient déjà nombreux à
prendre la route de la bretagne ou du
sud ouest à la veille de ce week-end de
grands départs le ministre délégué aux
transports jean baptiste djebbari est
venu constater ces flux de circulation
au péage de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines en
plein contexte de crise sanitaire les
réservations de train ont baissé de 25%
elle est française se reportent
davantage sur des trajets en voiture
pour leur séjour sur le sol national
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'à une partie des
personnes des français qui se sont
reportés sur leurs voitures
particulières
parce que certainement ils ont considéré
que c'était un environnement sanitaire
contrôler parce qu'ils voyagent en
famille ou qui se sont organisés pour
prendre leur voiture qui leur est
apparue j'imagine à ce moment là le
moyen de transport le plus simple est un
moyen de transport privilégié pour ces
vacances là qu'ils sont
on l'a dit des vacances permet assez
particulière avec un virus toujours sa
culotte et tout le monde qui vous mène
d'ailleurs être masqué une visite pour
faire passer des messages de prévention
notamment concernant la sécurité du
personnel autoroutier avec qui le
ministre a pu échanger en 2019 145
accidents ont été recensés lors
d'interventions et d'ailleurs qui ont
lieu très souvent sur la bande d'arrêt
d'urgence il ya toujours trop de heurts
deux fourgons notamment des
patrouilleurs part souvent faute de
vigilance au volant par utilisation de
des téléphones au volant et c'est
l'occasion aussi à vos micros de
rappeler évidemment l'obligation pour
soi et pour les autres de respecter les
mesures de sécurité routière rappeler
également que les dangers sont nombreux
au volant la somnolence est la première
cause de mortalité sur autoroute
quelques gestes de prudence sont donc de
mise pour les automobilistes
on les incite à vraiment être attentif à
leur niveau d'éveil dès les premiers
signes de somnolence à s'arrêter pour
faire une pause
le mieux c'est de faire une pause une
sieste pendant dix minutes un quart
d'heure c'est ce qui permet le plus de
retrouver un bon niveau d'éveil pour
ensuite continuer sa route en toute
sécurité
pour ce troisième week-end des vacances
d'été bison futé voit rouge dans le sens
des départs sur les routes d'île de
france pour la journée du samedi 18
juillet
[Musique]
les vacances scolaires ont débuté le 3
juillet dernier vous êtes peut-être en
recherche d'activités familiales et en
plein air dans le département et
justement en communication avec nous
nous avons vincent couteau de l'île de
loisirs bonjour bonjour
il doit dire de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et frédéric
drieu de la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet bonjour bonjour alors merci
à tous les deux d'avoir accepté
l'invitation pour commencer deux mois
après la fin du confinement on observe
légère reprise de transmission du
coronavirus plus que jamais les gestes
barrière doivent être respectés et le
ministre de l'intérieur jean castex a
annoncé le port du masque obligatoire
dans les lieux publics clos dès la
semaine prochaine alors le point commun
entre vos deux yeux c'est qu'ils sont
largement en extérieur mais tous deux
mènent concerne comment vous avez
adapter vos activités aux mesures
sanitaires je vais commencer avec vous
vincent couteau alors nous étions chaque
chaque secteur d'activité en
fonctionnement qui lui est propre et
donc un protocole sanitaire qui a été
adapté prenons un exemple de du parcours
accrobranche on impose le port du masque
surtout les temps qui sont en relation
directement avec les opérateurs
ça va être le temps du briefing de
l'initiation pendant les évacuations sur
parcours par contre dans le cadre du
parcours effectivement les usagers
peuvent enlever le masque est pratiqué à
sans problème la montre entre les
activités on a on a adapté les sens et
circulation et les protocoles en
fonction des temps de l'étang d'action
et côté de la bergerie nationale paraît
du coup on a imaginé un sens de
circulation qui ne se faisait pas
forcément paravent donc du coup j'ai
l'idée c'est de rentrer d'un d'un côté
ressortir de l'autre donc et d'éclairer
les visiteurs sont dans un bâtiment que
ça soit dans l'espace d'accueil dans
l'espace de la salle de traite la le
masque devient obligatoire mais
effectivement les trois quarts du trajet
se font à l'extérieur donc un protocole
a été mis en place pour justement éviter
de se croiser sans l'exploitation
agricole
alors cet été le message était beaucoup
de rester en france
est ce que vous observez un public
différent par rapport aux saisons à
dernière donc j'ai commencé avec vous
cette fois ci dans son couteau
alors différent je dirais pas ça par
contre vraiment un retour du public
vraiment très marquée depuis le
dégonflement globalement c'est vrai que
les deux heures ces 600 hectares
d'espacés verts et de nature dont on
peut trouver des coins où on est on est
tranquille tout seul voilà qui on a
aussi on sent aussi que les usagers les
franciliens pour moment partir loin on
l'a vu avec les services jeunesse par
exemple qui vont plutôt rester dans le
département est plutôt le calme en est
donc là on a davantage de public local
en tout cas le qui vient sur les dom à
dire effectivement frédéric drieu même
constat oui il nous paraît je pense que
la fréquentation est plutôt bonne on a
réouvert début début juin en espérant
pouvoir et accueillir des écoles mais ça
n'a pas été le cas donc du coup le le le
l'exploitation été ouverte pour les
familles qui ont du coup adhéré au
projet à la tout ce qui a été mis en
place par rapport au protocole et donc
du coup il a hélas depuis début juin
avec tes vacances et tout ce que le
gouvernement l'état le département la
région et ont mis en place que ce soit
quartiers d'été vacances apprenantes et
colas prenante du coup ça fonctionne
plutôt bien on a des centres de loisirs
et effectivement les enfants de
rambouillet qui normalement avait prévu
de partir en colo assez loin on monte
des projets que la bergerie pour pouvoir
redécouvrir la bergerie est resté
localement ce sera en juillet
normalement si on parle en paix les
programmations de ct à la bergerie vous
nous plonger dans un monde olympique si
les vins compris c'était prévu de longue
date
l'idée c'était de préparer les jeux
olympiques 2024 donc il est d'imaginer
un parcours ludique sur la ferme en lien
avec les jeux olympiques
donc l'idée c'est effectivement proposer
des choses qui sont ludiques sur la
thématique des jeux olympiques mais
toujours en ayant un lien avec le monde
agricole je vais prendre l'exemple de du
golfe champêtre qui se fait dans une
prairie au milieu des palmipèdes canards
et des oies l'idc
pas de parcourir cette animation est de
découvrir les différentes plantes
fourragères de la prairie l'activité sur
la traction animale c'est de faire une
comparaison entre la horde du cheval de
trait c'était un enfant ou un adulte est
capable de tirer le saut en longueur
c'est de comparer ce que nous on peut
sauter par rapport à l'animal de la
basse-cour etc
voilà donc vraiment la piscine de paille
c'est finalement la natation et de
découvrir la litière des litières des
animaux voilà c'est tout un ensemble
d'activités ludiques en lien avec les
jeux olympiques et le monde agricole
kalim de loi dit on à un village
culturel et sportif avec des activités
originelles oui on proposera pendant
quatre semaines
une multitude d'activités ont peu joué
une quinzaine d'activités qui sont
proposés c'est un projet qui est soutenu
par la région et en france à destination
initialement des publics 11 17 ans mais
vu le caractère un peu tardif 2-1 du
lancement des réservations on a encore
des créneaux disponibles
on a mis en place un outil en ouvre tous
les jours des créneaux au grand public
et donc tous les jours le grand public
peut s'initier à des activités vraiment
original vraiment fun qui était disc
golf et hockey sur gazon aujourd'hui
c'est c'est pia 5 et baseball five c'est
bon sympa c'est à dire pendant les
quatre semaines donc c'est ouvert du
coup au grand public qu'on accueille sur
l'espace elle mentionne dû coûter la
bergerie faut réserver aussi avant de
venir n'ont pas obligatoirement dans les
individuels vienne libre revendre c'est
là que les vacances d'été
la fréquentation permet
de ne pas réserver comparé aux autres
vacances où effectivement il ya sûrement
plus de monde on l'a on là il faut voir
par rapport aux franciliens qui reste
localement sur sur sur la région
parisienne mais pour la priory a pas
besoin de raids de réserver via clé les
centres de loisirs les groupes
constitués qui ont l'obligation de
réserver pour justement limiter la
fréquentation aussi sur la
surexploitation
alors pour conclure avant son compte au
comment vous abordé c'est un festival
finalement est bon la porte on aborde
avec beaucoup de temps vit déjà après
avoir été considérée comme tout le monde
pendant trois mois beaucoup d'optimisme
et puis on n'a finalement pas mal de en
plus de nos activités traditionnelles
pour pas mal de dispositifs qui sont qui
sont déclenchées et donc on va voir la
semaine prochaine
partir en livre par exemple retour de la
bande dessinée donc avec un petit camion
qui va s'ouvrir de tous les côtés pour
proposer plein d'animations hyper sympa
avec aussi des guérites était autour de
la bd on va avoir les tréteaux de france
qui vont revenir fin août avec ce
magnifique projet de théâtre aussi bien
des ateliers que les pièces on a on va
mettre en place une 100 m une allée en
fait un parcours fraîcheur avec 100 m de
brumisateurs accessible gratuitement au
public
donc on voit finalement finalement même
si tout a été long à se mettre en place
parce que parce que les choses se sont
dépensées un peu un peu au dernier
moment eh bien on a une belle
programmation pour pour tous les saint
quentinois et tous les franciliens pour
cet été une question pour vous ferez des
grieux bah pareil
du coup c'est vrai que le projet de
bergeron olympique et un nouveau projet
portait donc du coup parler parler les
animateurs fraîchement arrivé à la
bergerie est de pouvoir proposer cette
nouvelle thématique avec des animations
assez original voilà nous a donné
vraiment envie d'imaginer des choses des
choses sympas et comme le public est
pour l'instant au rendez vous et avec
toujours cette nécessité de découvrir le
monde le monde agricole avec cas
d'activités en lien avec eux la
chèvrerie la traite
achetez soins aux animaux et d'avoir
finalement élargi le sens le sens de
circulation en en permettant aussi au
public d'aller d'aller dans les prairies
au contact au contact des animaux
justement par rapport à cette
distanciation tizi que finalement ça a
apporté un aussi un renouveau sur le
faire donc de sites qui se complètent
bien pour des vacances yvelinoise plein
d'activités en plein air merci à tous
les deux doivent être rendus disponibles
pour cette interview merci les
différents programmes de la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet elite de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
sont à retrouver sur vos sites internet
respectifs qui se sont affichées durant
cet entretien on passe au reste de
l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
après les conseils d'installation des
mairies c'était au tour de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines d'élire ses représentants
samedi 11 juillet le conseil
d'agglomération s'est tenue au vélodrome
nationale en raison de la crise
sanitaire
sans surprise jean michel fourgous
conserve la présidence
retour sur cette séance avec rigueur et
canale et les lan hypothèse je déclare
donc monsieur fourgous président de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin encourage avoir un nouveau
mandat de six ans pour le maire les
républicains d'elancourt pour ce conseil
d'agglomération de la mandature 2020
2026 jean michel fourgous était seul
candidat à sa succession
une présidence qu'il place sous le signe
de l'emploi et des entreprises pour
répondre à la crise sociale
notre enjeu prioritaire sera l'emploi
bien sûr et la sauvegarde de notre tissu
économique et du niveau de vie de nos
douze commun c'est notre devoir d'élus
locaux d'aider les jeunes français à
entrer aussi sur le marché du travail
ça va être un moment difficile nous ne
devons pas avoir une génération
sacrifiée une élection aussi pour quinze
vice-présidents comme en 2017 jean
michel fourgous a choisi de donner des
délégations aux quatre maires de gauche
françois morton édile de guyancourt et
nouvel élu communautaire hérite de la
politique de la ville de la santé et des
solidarités
je pense que c'est important la
politique de la ville je la connais bien
je la pratique au niveau de mes en cours
depuis maintenant presque la totalité du
mandat puisque j'ai été élu à la
politique de la ville et la santé est
évidemment un enjeu primordial
après la période que nous venons de
ville vivre et les solidarités c'est
l'adn de la ville de guyancourt nouveaux
conseillers aussi lorrain merker qui est
en charge de l'urbanisme et de
l'aménagement du territoire
il devient aussi le premier vice
président de l'agglomération
ce que je veux retenir surtout moi ce
matin c'est la cohésion qui a eu au
niveau de tous les élus
un grand sens des responsabilités de
chacun et je trouve ça très encourageant
est très enthousiasmant pour les six
années à venir et le fait de voir tous
les élus quels que soient leurs bords
qui souhaitent travailler ensemble de
cette manière je pense qu'on va pouvoir
bien bien travailler pendant ses six
années l'environnement et la transition
écologique thèmes forts de la dernière
campagne des municipales sont confiés à
la mère de plaisir joséphine coleman
bergès l'environnement en tant que tel
fait partie de quelque chose de
transversale on va le retrouver
absolument partout j'ai déjà évoqué avec
certains vices présidents cette
nécessité de travailler ensemble que ce
soit sur l'habitat que ce soit même dans
les commerces dans le développement
économique
aujourd'hui on ne peut plus inscrire un
développement économique sans tenir
compte de l'environnement jean michel
fourgous a prévenu les conseillers
communautaires ce mandat sera celui du
rassemblement face aux difficultés
sanitaires et économiques
parmi les gros projets à la charge de
l'agglomération l'accueil de plusieurs
épreuves sportives lors des jeux
olympiques de 2024
ils étaient deux à se porter candidat
pour représenter la droite aux élections
législatives de la 11e circonscription
des yvelines
mercredi c'est finalement philippe
benassaya qui a été désigné par les
républicains othman nassr ou récemment
nommé vice président de la région ile de
france et son suppléant
on vous retrace le parcours politique du
candidat arrivé dans la ville de bois
d'arcy en 2008 où il échoue aux
élections municipales et se retrouve
dans l'opposition
philippe benassaya se représente en 2014
avec une liste de rassemblement ump udf
il mène une campagne avec une forte
opposition au projet immobilier du
centre-ville défendu par le maire
sortant
il crée alors la surprise en faisant
basculer la ville à droite le maire ps
sortant claude vieillit et est élu
depuis 19 ans en 2015 il transforme
l'essai avec les départementales en
binôme avec sonia bros actuel maire de
saint cyr l'école
il remporte le canton ancré à gauche
depuis 1997 et participe au grand chelem
de la droite à ces élections c'est une
confirmation c'est une consolidation de
nos résultats dans nos villes c'est un
encouragement et sport du travail qu'on
a fait depuis un an au département il
est notamment président d'ingenico
l'organisme qui aide les petites
communes dans l'élaboration de projets
en 2020 il a été réélu maire de bois
d'arcy dès le premier tour avec plus de
60% des voix
ça fait quand même une assise importante
on est obligé de se poser la question
quand il est licite hâtive partiel
surtout quand on fait ces résultats là
dans une ville et dans un canton on se
dit qu'on est peut-être peut-être le
plus habilité pour pour y aller et puis
je j'ai été conforté surtout parlé par
l'appui que j'ai reçus d'à peu près les
parlementaires tous les parlementaires
de ma famille politique que des yvelines
gérard larcher bien sûr pierre bédier
valérie pécresse jean michel fourgous le
présente 50 heures avec othman nasri
comme suppléant il entend représenter la
force du travail d'un élu proche du
terrain dans les crises successives que
la france vienne 2 vient de subir crises
sociales et économiques crise sanitaire
la réponse quand même est venu très
souvent des collectivités pas du haut
elle est venue d'en bas et nous
représentons lui et moi cette france
ceux du terrain cette france des
territoires cette france des
collectivités
pour l'heure il est seul candidat
déclaré pour ces législatives partielles
nadia est désormais ministre a assuré
qu'il y aurait une candidature de la
république en marche
quant à la gauche à lire ab nouveau
maire de trappes souhaite convaincre
benoît hamon de faire son retour
jeudi la présidente de la région ile de
france et rendu au site renault de flins
une visite de l'établissement industriel
yves binois ainsi qu'une rencontre de la
direction et des partenaires sociaux au
coeur des échanges le plan d'économies
de 2 milliards d'euros du groupe renault
avec la transformation de l'activité du
site
les explications de nicolas landry la
région ile-de-france au soutien de
l'usiné renault de flins lors de sa
visite la présidente valérie pécresse
est venue rappeler sa volonté de
maintenir la production de véhicules sur
ce site industriel une position
contraire aux annonces de la direction
du groupe
la transformation de l'activité de
l'usiné de flins consacré dans un plan
d'économies global de deux milliards
d'euros
la direction de renault a un projet elle
a un projet basé sur l'économie
circulaire qui est un projet très
intéressant mais qui doit se conjuguer
avec la volonté de tous les élus du
territoire de continuer de produire des
voitures ici à flins alors la région va
essayer de faire tout ce qui est en son
pouvoir pour convaincre l'état qu'il ne
faut pas d industrialiser la vallée de
la seine actuellement la nissan micra et
le véhicule électrique zoé sortent
chaque jour des lignes de production de
l'usiné créée en 1952 l'établissement
emploie près de 2600 personnes
la région souhaite participer à sa
compétitivité et à son attractivité
la région pourrait intervenir pour
rénover complètement la centrale
thermique du site qui est vétuste et qui
pourrait se transformer en une belle
centrales de production d'énergie
peut-être même pour le territoire
durant cette visite valérie pécresse a
rencontré les partenaires sociaux des
syndicats engagés actuellement dans des
négociations avec la direction du groupe
madame pécresse on la sent très investis
c'est une personne qui veut vraiment
faire bouger les choses et qui veut
vraiment pas à préserver l'emploi et la
région en la matière la production de
véhicules notamment du véhicule
électrique véhicule propre et quand même
un des véhicules les plus vendus sur la
région parisienne
l'état la région les pouvoirs publics de
règne des milliards d'argent public dans
les poches de renault et renault
annoncent la fermeture de sites
la suppression de postes l'arrêt de
fabrication de voitures à flot et c'est
une nouvelle réunion entre les
partenaires sociaux et la direction du
groupe est prévue courant septembre pour
faire un point sur la restructuration
un recours d'annulation du scrutin
déposée par neal est due à la verrière
l'ex maire communiste a perdu son
fauteuil le 28 juin dernier
devancé de 56 voix par nicolas dainville
celle qui siège désormais dans
l'opposition un vent que le respect des
droits et de la démocratie dénonçant les
mensonges et attaques subies pendant la
campagne
le dossier est entre les mains du
tribunal administratif de versailles
nelly dit tu es nicolas dainville
interrogé par nicolas landry
il y a très peu de voix d'écart et il
nous semble que la la campagne de
monsieur dainville à des procédés qu'on
peut remettre en cause
on pense que dans le traitement du col
vide est la période de confinement il
peut y avoir des choses à revoir la
diffamation
aussi bien pour mon appartement que pour
le fait que j'aurais interdit à la
police de intervenir sur la ville ce qui
est archifaux une personne de confession
musulmane qui quelques jours avant
l'élection dit très précisément qu'il ne
faut pas voter pour moi parce que je
suis communiste et athée et qu'il fait
voter monsieur der wiel parce qu'il est
chrétien certes mais au moins croyants
l'association demande à verrières a
démenti et y être pour quelque chose
je suis l'association
et bien sûr le son démenti a été mis
dans notre dossier c'est une démarche
assez classique pour les candidats qui
perdent une élection c'est vrai que je
regrette cette démarche là parce que
j'ai un peu l'impression que c'est
l'hôpital qui se moque de la charité
c'est qu'on a nous notre équipe subit un
certain nombre d'irrégularités
tout au long de cette campagne on a
réussi à gagner justement parce que
beaucoup d'habitants en avaient
ras-le-bol de ces méthodes c'est
pratique et on a je dirais l'attitude
une mauvaise perdante qui nous on nous
reproche tout un tas de choses qui sont
assez dérisoire je suis très serein sur
l'issue de cette procédure
la ministre délégué à la ville nadia et
s'est rendu jeudi à mantes la ville
la commune compte deux quartiers
prioritaires de la politique de la ville
et sort tout juste d'une mandature duras
on demande nationale
l'ex député viennoise a échangé avec les
associations et le nouveau maire sans
étiquette mais soutenu par l'union de la
droite sami damerdji objectif renforcer
les aides pour soutenir la cohésion
sociale les associations qui dit s'être
senti délaissé durant six ans est le
nouveau maire faisant le constat
d'infrastructures non entretenues les
propos recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude l'enjeu qui va être aujourd'hui
pour la nouvelle équipe municipale c'est
justement de rétablir la cohésion
sociale c'est de ramener la république
parce que quand on décide de retirer des
financements du milieu associatif
c'est quelque part la république qui se
retire nadia et que vous allez justement
retrouver dans notre rubrique ça s'est
passé en 2010 est là désormais ministre
était élu député de la 11e
circonscription elle l'emportait au
deuxième tour face à jean michel
fourgous
[Musique]
il est d'un peu plus de 21h quand jean
michel fourgous le candidat l'est
républicain vient annoncer sa défaite
dans la 11e circonscription des yvelines
sa seule satisfaction être en tête dans
sa ville d'elancourt
c'est vrai que mais toujours une petite
déception mais je dirais qu'il ya une
stèle tsunami et nationales que écoutez
je suis content de voir que ma ville n'a
pas pris l'eau entre guillemets elle a
été touchée par ce n'est ni bon c'est là
où je travaille le plus quand même
les résultats sont partiels mais il sait
déjà qu'il ne remportera pas ce siège de
député que lui a ravie benoît hamon il
ya cinq ans jean michel fourgous adresse
alors un salut républicain à la gagnante
qu'il va croiser plus tôt que prévu
nadia est rejoint en effet la mairie
d'elancourt après s'être saluer et avoir
transmis quelques conseils
c'est l'occasion aussi pour les deux
adversaires de quelques mises au point
après des échanges tendus pendant la
campagne le déclare actif c'est bien le
léger mieux c'est
donc ils vont bien que les gens
attendent bien sûr mais pas rapide
difficile gagnante nouvelle en politique
après une campagne de terrain a relayé
le message du président de la république
voit ses efforts récompensés
elle est élue avec 52,96 % des voix
contre 47 0 4%
pour jean michel fourgous un 2e tour
marqué par un record d'abstention 58,3 %
en forte augmentation par rapport au
premier tour
je suis effectivement extrêmement
satisfaite des du résultat après après
-selon semaine de travail ces longues
semaines où te suis allé à la rencontre
de nous de nos concitoyens et c'est
aussi une grande fierté aujourd'hui pour
moi d'en arriver là effectivement il ya
quelques mois j'étais cadre dans une
banque aujourd'hui je suis député à
l'assemblée nationale auprès du
président emmanuel macron donc pour moi
c'est d'autant plus une immense fierté
de porter un projet un projet comme
celui là qui est de celui de celui de la
république en marche à seulement 37 ans
cette femme active cadre à paris est
originaire de trappes devient la 11e
députés en marche des yvelines ces
priorités d'élus la moralisation de la
vie politique et la réforme du code de
travail qu emmanuel macron compte mettre
en oeuvre dès cet été
elle va mettre en place une permanence
dans sa circonscription et a lancé une
plateforme collaborative pour donner la
parole aux habitants de la 11e
circonscription
[Applaudissements]
après une soirée où elle retrouve sa
famille ses amis ses soutiens et les
marcheurs elle salue tous ceux qui l'ont
accompagné durant cette campagne vous a
guidé votre temps
ce n'est pas tant professionnelles le
temps familial parfois effectivement ça
se complique et je fais mais vous l'avez
paix et je vous remercierai jamais assez
pour reconstruire l été et oui nous
l'avons fait nous avons battu avant nous
avons 21 ans michel fargo elle sait
qu'elle va devoir s'installer vite pour
travailler dans ces bureaux de
l'assemblée
elle y partira d'ailleurs pour une
visite dès demain matin avant une
session de formation pour les nouveaux
arrivants et la journée d'ouverture de
la prochaine législature avec l'ensemble
des députés prévu le 27 juin
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette dernière émission
de la saison mais ne vous inquiétez pas
tv soit 118 vous accompagne tout au long
de l'été avec des reportages quotidiens
et pour moi aussi cette émission marque
une fin la fin de cette aventure au sein
de votre télévision locale
j'adresse des remerciements particuliers
à mes collègues les journalistes bien
sûr mais aussi les monteurs réalisateur
s'enquit émissions et reportages
n'existerait pas sans oublier
l'infographiste indispensable pour
rentrer là pour rendre l'information
parfois plus lisible j'ai appris de vous
toutes et tous enfin je vous remercie
vous les yvelinois alors ceux qui nous
regardent bien sûr mais aussi tout ce
que j'ai pu rencontrer sur le terrain et
en plateau j'ai passé deux belles années
à vos côtés ce sont bien sûr toutes ces
rencontres qui font la richesse de ce
métier
alors je vous dis au revoir et peut-être
à bientôt ailleurs et bien sûr belle
était sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour
[Musique]